hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hello neighbor now
we've made a bit of an error here I
exited out of the game and I didn't
realize that it wasn't going to save my
progress so everything that I've done up
until this point is for naught and I
have not made any progress but that's
okay because generally speaking I know
where to go from here but uh at the same
time I don't think the neighbors Wow
I am just stuck still aren't I the
neighbors gonna be wandering around
again and I know it was a little bit
cheaty for him to be stuck in a wall or
a window while I was prancing around his
house but that's okay
because I know where everything is now
and I also would I don't know what the
[ __ ] happened okay physics got weird for
a second there although I can't see [ __ ]
yes okay I got the magnet so that's good
and then I can utilize this to be able
to do what I need to do but the only
problem why again already that's a
little early don't you think but I'm
gonna do this before you got me hey hi
hey [ __ ] I forgot how scary was I went
so long without him getting me that I
totally forgot that he's actually a pret
what I got to do is I got to get in his
house now I got a week I got a sneak
everywhere so I also need a flashlight
and I'm pretty sure this one up here
I'll be back once I get everything that
I need and I explore this guy's weird
ass house I just wish there was a clue
to know when he was a common enough
lights really are limited in the
distance but least the powers on here I
think that's a good thing
hey [ __ ] I don't know where you are I
haven't opened all the side doors yet
you second she stopped love it that yeah
under noise and you're at bag of dicks
ah [ __ ] you Khalu there's no skipping
steps for that boy ha ha ha you know
what I'm gonna bash open one of the
windows of whoopsies I'm gonna bash up
and once these I'm gonna bash you up and
Wonder
one of the windows in the back and that
way I'll be able to flip [ __ ] a
cabinet he saw me for a goddamn window
probably home probably because it got my
flashlight on son's gonna be stealthy
about it not that one
one back here that I kinda play us okay
so let's just break some property huh
hey he'll not notice that in a million
yours
oh well that sandy you just hop over it
that makes my life way easier okay habit
abuse key Harbor Debus key happen to
moose key okay I'm not gonna open that
yet because I don't know Hey Oh shucks
darn it okay yeah forget about me okay
I'm gonna make this on the first try
buddy boo I'm gonna make this on the
first try
ah [ __ ] I've got a bit of a problem but
that's okay oh oh it is the face oh
that's that's horrifying
oh [ __ ] too early too early on the
hippity hop this is gonna take me a long
time but puppet whoa hey yeah yeah get
this the [ __ ] out of here uh-oh was
about to say [ __ ] your face but I don't
think that's kosher you got that put
that there
pick that up got that okay E yeah yeah
nice whoa [ __ ] ah [ __ ] nice mustache
[ __ ] absolutely she doesn't take my
[ __ ] anymore how really really oh and he
fixed his dang window
what up bunch up to me Nikki sneaky
[ __ ] threw the key god damn it I just
threw the key why did I throw the key oh
no oh no where did I throw the key what
the focus of the hook k here's the earth
round do appetit Boop and open oh hi and
close I forgot you were standing there
you big dingus okay so I'm gonna assume
that I don't need this key anymore I'm
gonna drop this key off that's gonna be
the last of it
roughly where I was before but the only
problem is I need to get back over here
so hey Rick I'm good how about you you
want to go for a ride oh wow huh got
that one huh okay there we go got it
okay everything's happy and fun I'm
gonna move you you're in move whoa
what's up I forgot uh look I forgot that
he's actually a threat again it was so
nice when he didn't bother me like an
a-hole also I need this up there I need
to be able to see what why am I still
holding this lamp oh [ __ ] it's so
problematic when he's going around doing
all his [ __ ] how can he know how can
she slap
how can he slap my ass okay now that he
stopped being a douche nozzle maybe I
should be able to speak into your
goddamn house I don't even like your
house that much it's a big bag of asses
so are you I hate you and you smell bad
what are you doing to me family your
friends got him [ __ ] again okay you
know what I'm going for it I'm going for
it I'm launching no and actually I'm
going down here go go
just four enough [ __ ] hole you ass
okay you know what I needed to go down
here because I need to get this can you
open thank you can you grab that thank
you [ __ ] why is everything got to be
such dick 'try all the time every moment
of my days filled with dicks at all
times why oh I see what I gotta do oh I
know oh I know about that oh I don't
know how I'm gonna get there though
maybe from the outside I can get in
there but I don't think so okay I want
to go back down but I gotta go back down
because I got no other way to go here we
go good [ __ ] close I'm on time crunch
now it dies it [ __ ] get out of the
way you goddamn chair huh yes okay wow
they're open they're not broken again
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] I don't have anything on me
that I can throw I guess I could throw
this I'll come back for you
you didn't even break it you ass man it
is really inconvenient within actually
being there let's try this again I'll
get the magnets and get any eat it you
never know three two
launched yes okay and then I'm just
gonna go out this one cuz I don't think
there's anything else anywhere else that
I need whoa oh no no no how can you get
up here you can't that's the answer
yeah BuChE BuChE BuChE hubble's ha ha
hot okay hot ok ok cool how the [ __ ] do
I get over this one because I know I got
to get over that one it's like there's
two platforms that I could go down but I
got to be able to get there first
the unfortunate thing is there's nothing
really I guess I could catch my fault I
just go straight into it ha no this is
this is problematic why would this be
here if you couldn't do this once it's
like a key or something that I can
magnetize from this juncture running
Stuart close yes ok we made it here Oh
what does this mean
oh I'm up here I'm on his house ok so
there's a drop-in over there that looks
scary oh that's a scary please I need
like uh I need like a platform maybe if
I go down here yeah oh yeah
whoa whoa okay be careful be careful oh
wait I could have broken this at any
time I could have broken through this
damn window why midnight I didn't even
think about that huh well no no oh yeah
well I need you I need you for stuff
no stop throwing it jeez there anything
I can get
stop oh my god what [ __ ] why oh god
oh god oh god oh god do not come out
here whoa whoa whoa whoa you just
install that this entire [ __ ] god
dammit you [ __ ] off [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
you know I [ __ ] you and it's such dick I
could have gotten in that room I didn't
even [ __ ]
I didn't even [ __ ] [ __ ] stop stop
what a dick hole he's putting bear traps
everywhere because he's an ass [ __ ] I
just want to go to the door
uh-uh can you for one just not move why
every time are you just there every time
now is that is that your prerogative
just to be there every time oh my god
you are that is it you [ __ ] ass are
you know what I'll come back to that
because I don't even have the means with
which to rip off the door
qapla ah [ __ ] uh again never leaves
that place never leave never leave oh
come on
[ __ ] god damn it [ __ ] this ass
Oh is he right here is he right here no
for one who's not ok ok so that's like
that but I still owe here through the
keyhole here whoa oh no that's just a
bug ok can't see in there there's
nothing to see so I now unlocked it was
a keycard but what I didn't do is unlock
it with the crowbar which I don't even
know where it is it was under a bed last
time but I highly doubt it's gonna be
there again he put so many cameras up
there
what a dick what it just did I [ __ ]
threw my [ __ ] flashlight did I really
throw my [ __ ] flashlight the answer
is yes I did like an [ __ ] and I'll
never be able to find it again unless I
use this lamp to find it down the bad
location for a [ __ ] flashlight that I
accidentally why good god this guy is
such a problem look that doesn't make
any sense I'm in the shadows how do you
know that doesn't make any sense I just
gotta get back in again how it doesn't
make any sense
oh [ __ ] off how and why it's like his
vision is like if you're anywhere even
in the vicinity of where he is you're
blocked I think I got to turn off power
to his house because it's just getting
too much of a problem to have him be
able to like I think the cameras number
one are bad
okay Sebastian well eat a bag of dicks
effected
eat a bag of big ol dicks I just want to
get back up to where I was
all-in-one Wow
what does that go I don't get it
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] I don't get it he's
so like it's impossible now why he why
is it suddenly impossible I mean [ __ ]
man it's like I'm in pitch darkness and
he still sees me it was not as bad I
mean I guess he got stuck so could have
been that bad but how I mean I guess he
could have heard the [ __ ] window
breaking but other than that man he is
overbearing what oh oh no oh no oh no
huh oh why why I don't have a flashlight
[ __ ] you god dammit it's absurd like
something is obviously wrong here I
can't even get in a [ __ ] house
anymore oh my god I can't see anything
anymore because there's no lamp in here
give me you where's the hole in the
ground [ __ ] I have no idea where I am
I can't see a goddamn thing cuz I took
the lamp out of here on the [ __ ] hole
drop me in the [ __ ] hole I'm right on
it aren't I oh I was I was on it I was
on the hole there [ __ ] oh my god I don't
have a [ __ ] flashlight so now I have
a box I have one box that took me
[ __ ] forever I meant to get another
buck why is it darken oh because I
turned all the power off I got to turn
that back on because it literally did
nothing for me
hope come on
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't see I
don't have a [ __ ] flashlight god
[ __ ] damn it I lost my box oh this is
infuriating this is [ __ ] infuriating
I'm gonna go down here [ __ ] out of my
way bucket get the [ __ ] out
it's a [ __ ] bucket what [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
hey I hate this oh that's the right spot
there we go okay all right I'm pretty
high up don't freak out on me oh my god
you are not gonna tell me that I need to
go [ __ ] over somewhere else I need to
go over the goddamn lip with a goddamn
thing again you know what I'm just gonna
do it this way not because that didn't
work there we go again this way hook now
walking what's up
[ __ ] oh yo yo yo yo yo yo yo I know what
to do I know what to do oh my god okay
there we go I'm up oh I [ __ ] forgot
you better [ __ ] nail this on the dot
thank you [ __ ] don't don't even
bother
can't you can't [ __ ] get me bro get
[ __ ] wrecked dick hole dick hole okay
now here's the million dollar question
can I make this jump not if he keeps
flashing me with goop juice
oh he [ __ ] threw a glue while I was
mid [ __ ] a girl I just want to make
progress I just want to make progress I
haven't made a single step of progress
since I started this episode I have not
made a single step towards my goal
because he is the most sensitive piece
of [ __ ] I've ever seen in my life
it's like he thinks my flashlight is on
permanently
well I got in here didn't think that was
gonna happen through my flashlight away
but now I'm here that's that's the thing
can I shoot him can I shoot him in his
[ __ ] face
can I [ __ ] shoot him I don't have a
flashlight so I don't even know if
there's a door here so if I'm not
mistaken I got in an area where I was
supposed to have a golden key and now I
have a gun can I shoot him [ __ ] what
okay that doesn't make any goddamn sense
oh well now this is open at least so I
got this and now I have a gun I'm gonna
shoot this [ __ ] [ __ ] come after me
I [ __ ] dare you you want to see if
I'm messing with you [ __ ] you want to
see come after me I [ __ ] dare you
oh there's my old flashlight you know
what I'll have to cuz that's how I roll
oh whoa you coming after me Oh meet me
at my house step over the line step over
this line step over the line huh no [ __ ]
that all that [ __ ] did the [ __ ]
piddly little [ __ ] is this [ __ ] it's
unlimited isn't it yeah how the [ __ ] do
you like it huh [ __ ] you yeah that's
right [ __ ] you I'm gonna shoot out every
[ __ ] window in your [ __ ] house
what you saw something no you didn't
because [ __ ] you what you thought you
could give me [ __ ] [ __ ] you and I'm a
[ __ ] good thing is I should be able to
keep him that Bay with this I mean this
is literally this is literally a
neighbor repellent this is what this is
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off what's
[ __ ] No oh my god that was close I
don't know where you are I can't see
[ __ ] Dawg the shooting wildly [ __ ] no I
[ __ ] threw my goddamn flash my god
damn it hog I'm having the worst time
I've been playing this for almost an
hour now trying to make just the smidge
more progress but it doesn't [ __ ]
work Oh
all I need are few trash cans that I'm
gonna try desperately to get into that
[ __ ] loft but I [ __ ] threw my
pleasure I can't believe I'm [ __ ]
through oh good I got a spare I've got
two garbage cans
that's probably my best bet for getting
in there I don't know why don't ask me
why I don't know long as I don't throw
the wrong thing okay I'm gonna just put
these real close
where the [ __ ] did it go of course oh of
course it's [ __ ] disappeared okay you
know what
[ __ ] that maybe it has to do with this
no okay fine maybe I've been an idiot
this whole time and it's the goddamn
railroad tracks that are literally right
next to me maybe that's it because it
would it would be that because I'm dumb
and of course it's that up yep it would
be this wouldn't it no maybe it wouldn't
be this oh that's really [ __ ] closed
now isn't it okay so it's not this I
can't I was not supposed to come in here
why was there a [ __ ] where's your way
to get in why oh why why have you done
this to me
there's no [ __ ] reward here what was
the [ __ ] point then Oh No
I've been trying for over an hour to get
up here and there's no reason to there's
no reason to get up here and I bet I bet
the only way to get out of here is to
restock all of these boxes
all these boxes over here so that you
can get out that's the only way to get
out is why would you do that why would
you oh [ __ ] it you know what why do I
even want to get back out there it
doesn't [ __ ] matter are you know what
I'm all out of time for this because I'm
just tired I'm tired of it I haven't
done anything and I discovered that the
secrets that I wanted don't exist so I'm
going to leave it at that
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you got some tips and tricks
eggs it gets past this let me know down
in the comments below and as always in
the next video
[Music]